I'm stuck on google calendar now partly
because every device things once it
sinks well I mean up my iphone sync so
that my iPad sings with it my android
devices think whether you know obviously
Google's going to sync with her up
Keller do you know and Windows Mac and
everything syncs with it so I can use it
no matter world and I can use your
computer and use it and run so it's
great to have a cloud-based calendar see
you then it's going to be hard to rip
that away because because even if you
design a better counter with plancast
and for information or tripped
integration which actually there is some
tripping in motion next week next and
see what trip it did so trip the lowest
trick me about these things in rental
car and yeah I actually overlaid my
foursquare data which is an interesting
visualization start to see where you
check in using me where you're supposed
to be at what times yeah but kind of
coming back to your point a
paradigm-shifting calendar let's assume
that more or less they're all in the
same bucket and then I understand all
the kind of sailing point you're making
as far as google calendar is concerned
even amongst the early adopters which
you're kind of sitting at the top of
that e what's your sense and the kind of
openness and the ability to adopt
something that radically changes the way
to look at our time and when we met at
your time it's going to be tough it's
going to be tough to get me away from
this right now because of the lock-in of
iphone and android and ipad windows it
has to work everywhere and it has to be
built it i mean if you could convince
steve jobs to put here in your new
countering as the key we're we're hungry
yeah you know and i don't think that's
gonna be an easy thing to do cuz i know
i just want me to be Tuggle me know
you know I mean yeah it's just really
gonna be tough I mean eyes that's why I
like tundle because it uses google
calendar doesn't try to replace syrup
doesn't try to go no you can't use
google counter sorry it usually what
what works it's sort of Flipboard same
thing right Flipboard looks really cool
but underneath it's all Twitter sure
right now right or Facebook and it
doesn't try to replace Twitter or
Facebook it just says those things are
what they are and they're not going away
and we're going to use them and we're
going to use them and hide a little bit
but we're going to use them to create
something beautiful as the beauty of it
that matters not the magic underlie our
day the architect